FRANK, THANK YOU.
JOINING ME NOW IN D.C. IS BRET
BAIER AND CO-ANCHOR OF "SPECIAL
REPORT."
>> Bret: I WILL BE INTERESTED TO
HEAR WHAT SENATOR McCONNELL SAYS
ON YOUR SHOW.
IT'S WEIRD TO, TO BE IN THIS
SEAT IN THIS STUDIO.
>> Martha: THANKS FOR LETTING ME
DO THIS.
>> Bret: I LOOKED INTO THE
NUMBERS.
THERE ARE KEY THINGS THAT
YOUNGKIN HAS DONE IN VIRGINIA.
ONE IS LOOKING AT THE BLACK
VOTE.
HE GOT 13% OF THE BLACK VOTE.
DONALD TRUMP IN 2020 GOT 11%.
MITT ROMNEY GOT 8% AND JOHN
McCAIN 4%.
THERE IS A REPUBLICAN STORY TO
BE TOLD ABOUT THE BLACK
COMMUNITY AND CHIPPING AWAY AND
GETTING MORE VOTERS TO PAY
ATTENTION.
THIS IS A RACE WHERE THE PUNDITS
SAID THAT YOUNGKIN WAS BLOWING
THE RACIAL DOG WHISTLE AND
TRYING TO GET WHITE SUPREMACISTS
ENGAGED IN THE RACE.
THAT'S THE DYNAMIC MUCH MORE
BLACK VOTERS VOTED FOR THE
REPUBLICAN THAN IN THE PAST.
TO FRANK A POINT, THIS HAS
RAMIFICATIONS BROADER.
WE WILL SEE IN THE NEXT DAY OR
TWO THAT THIS MEANS ON CAPITOL
HILL.
I HAVE SENATOR JOE MANCHIN ON
THE SHOW TONIGHT ABOUT WHERE
MODERATESES WILL BE IN THE WAKE
OF AN ELECTORAL POLITICAL
EARTHQUAKE.
>> Martha: I AM LOOKING FORWARD
TO SENATOR MANCHIN INTERVIEW.
IT'S A QUESTION FOR HIM:
DOES HE FEEL EMPOWERED TODAY?
LIKE I TOLD YOU SO?
WHENLY AXALITY WHERE VOTERS ARE?
>> Bret: HE MAY NOT BE ALONE IN
SPEAKING UP ANYMORE.
>> Martha: AND THE BLACK VOTERS
ENTERING TO WATCH THAT SHIFT.
I WILL SPEAK TO THE LT. GOVERNOR
SEARS.
SHE HAD A GREAT SPEECH.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE JUST
LEARNING ABOUT HER FOR THE FIRST
TIME.
IT RAISES QUESTIONS ABOUT
EDUCATION.
THE INTERSECTIONS ARE NOT ALONG
RACIAL LINES ANYMORE.
DEMOCRATS ASSUMED THEY WOULD
STAY THAT.
>> Bret: BLACK MOMS AND DADS AND
HISPANIC MOMS AND DADS CARE
ABOUT THEIR KIDS AND WHAT THEY
ARE LEARNING.
THAT CROSS RACIAL LINES WHEN
THAT ISSUE HIT HOME.
I THINK REPUBLICANS WILL USE THE
EDUCATION UMBRELLA ISSUE IN THE
SUBURBS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
>> Martha: ONE OF MOST
INTERESTING LINES IN HER SPEECH,
I AM BLACK OBVIOUSLY, BUT IT'S
NOT ABOUT THAT.
THAT'S INTERESTING.
WE WILL TALK ABOUT THAT.
GOOD TO WORK WITH YOU.
LOVE YOUR NEW STUDIO.
IT'S GREAT AROUND HERE